and behold the word of the Lord came
unto him saying this shall not be thine
heir but he that shall come forth out of
thine own bowels should be 9 here
so he gets promised the impossible once
again and he brought him forth abroad
and said now look towards the heaven
until the Stars if thou be able to
number them and he said unto Him so
shall thy seed be and he believed in the
Lord and counted to him for
righteousness
seeing that this is the Covenant idea
this belief because here's the belief
it's the willingness to act as if the
world is constructed so that if you do
the right thing the best possible
outcome will occur it's a decision
that's the Covenant right it's a
decision about how to live in the world
because the evidence can't be there
before you make the decision right and
so you might hedge your bets
you know when when Christ comes back in
the book of Revelation to judge people
because it comes back as a judge and
virtually everyone gets cast out with
the chaff and not saved with the wheat
huh he says something very interesting
he appears in a vision with a sword
coming out of his mouth it's a
horrifying vision and he divides the the
he divides humanity into the Damned and
the save or the dead yes the Damned and
the saved he says something very
interesting he says to those who were
neither hot nor cold I will spew you out
of my mouth and and it's a it's a
disgust metaphor right and what it says
is that the worst punishment isn't
waiting for those who committed to
something and did wrong the worst
punishment is reserved for those who
committed to nothing and stayed on the
fence and that's really something to
that's really something to think about
and it's also something I believe to be
true because I see that stasis is
utterly destructive because there's no
progress all there is is movement
backwards there's aging
and suffering and no progress and so did
not commit to anything is the worst of
all transgressions to commit means to
put your body and soul into something to
offer your life as a sacrifice means
that you're willing to make a bargain
with fate and the bargain is I'm going
to act as if I give it my all
then the best possible thing will happen
because of that
and to to not see the analogy between
that and the the active faith in God is
to misunderstand the story completely
and it has to be an active faith because
how are you going to know you can look
at other people but that isn't going to
do it it's at Kierkegaard was very clear
about this sort of thing there's certain
sorts of truths that you can only learn
for yourself through experience and
that's of course why Abram also has to
go out alone right he has to leave this
kenneth's it's an individual it's the
individuation process like dying it's
something that you do alone there's no
way you can tell what is within your
grasp let's say unless you make the
ultimate sacrifice and there's no way of
finding out without actually making it
and so that's the sacrificial act right
that's that's really active Abram being
called upon to sacrifice Isaac you think
about that is Abram he's been doing he's
been like breaking himself into pieces
trying to progress forward to starvation
and tyranny and war and deceit and the
potential loss of his wife and child
lessness and like everything that can
really befall you in some sense and
finally God grant some Isaac when he's
old it's impossible he gets Isaac his
son and then what does God do next is
say well you know that son that you've
been waiting for so for so long it's
like I'd like to see just exactly what
you're made of so I think you should
offer him up as a sacrifice and I mean
it's a very barbaric story in a sense
and may be in more than just a sense but
Abraham does maintain his covenant he's
willing to make the sacrifice he's made
willing to make this is the thing he's
willing to make whatever sacrifice is
necessary to keep his covenant with God
intact and that's that